VRINDA SINGH: Perfect.
So what we're going
to do today is
have a discussion
with both of you
on what it takes to be Careem,
lessons from entrepreneurs
who have truly made
it big in the region,
and your personal stories.
So I have a lot of
questions around how
you both deal with each other.
Because no press interview
ever answers that.
And obviously Google
has an amazing culture,
but Careem has an
amazing culture as well.
And I think there are
always lessons to learn.
So that's something we would
like to understand from you.
And the last thing
we want to talk
about today is humility is a
big focus for culture at Careem.
And you've spoken
a lot about it.
And we'd like to understand
what that's all about.
And the format, so
we have 40 minutes.
So I'll give you
a few questions,
but it really is all up to you.
And then we'll open
up in the last 15
minutes for the audience
to take questions.
Sounds good?
Perfect.
And I will set it
on with this mic,
and hopefully it doesn't fall.
All right, so where do we start?
So Careem, it's
been five years now.
Where did it all begin
and what triggered it?
MAGNUS OLSSON: So as some
of you might have heard,
it started a bit more
than five years ago.
For me, the journey was I
was happily consulting away
in the region, enjoying myself.
I had been in the Middle East.
Now it's been 11 years.
I've been here since
2006 and really enjoyed
what I was doing.
But my life took
a bit of a turn.
I had a brain bleeding
out of nowhere.
And a very long story short,
I survived, which was great.
But it really gave me an
opportunity to reflect on life.
And what's life?
Why are you here?
And what's your purpose?
Why are we all running around?
And what are we going to do
with the time we have here?
And while I was very
happy at McKinsey,
I realized that this is
not my ultimate purpose.
I need to do something
really meaningful and big.
So I quit and went
looking for that purpose.
And in the process, me and
Mudassir started chatting,
and one thing led to another.
VRINDA SINGH: And
what for you was the--
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA:
So one was just
meeting Magnus and hearing his
mission was a big part of it.
But there were two
things that happened
in 2011, which is the year
before we started Careem,
that sort of triggered it.
One was I was part of a
start up in the valley that
got acquired.
So I just had more
financial freedom
to consider doing
something else.
And second, in the
last year at McKinsey,
we were looking to open
an office in Pakistan
where I'm from.
And since I was thinking
of leaving anyways,
I volunteered to go
in and explore it.
And one of the things
that we had to do
was to make a list of
clients that McKinsey
could serve in Pakistan.
McKinsey typically works
with larger organizations.
So we looked for
larger companies.
And I was quite surprised to
see that there was only one
company in Pakistan at that
time, which was worth more
than a billion dollars.
Pakistan is a nation
of 200 million people.
And there was only
one company that
was worth more than
a billion dollars.
And forget about the
billion dollar mark.
That's irrelevant.
But the fact that such
a large nation of people
has only produced one
large corporate institution
is a bit sad, a bit
embarrassing as well.
Why have we not been
able to produce it?
And I would joke with Magnus
that he's from Sweden.
And in Sweden, out of four
or five million people--
MAGNUS OLSSON: 10 now.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: 10 million?
They've produced an
Ericsson, a Volvo, an IKEA,
and the list goes on.
So there was some desire to go
out and build something really
big to prove to ourselves
that we can do it
and also hopefully to make an
impact in the lives of people
in the region.
So the fact that I had some
financial independence,
there was this thing that
was lurking in the back,
and then met Magnus
was the final push.
VRINDA SINGH: So the jump
into entrepreneurship--
a lot of people are
budding entrepreneurs.
One day I'm going
to do something.
Everyone says that.
Did you have this idea?
Or did you go through
a list of 100 ideas?
How did you hit upon the
idea of Careem as such?
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: Yes.
So we left what we were
doing before we had the idea.
So we said we want to do
something else, and we left.
And there were
two basic criteria
that we put on ourselves.
Whatever we end up doing
should have huge potential,
should have the
opportunity or the ability
to become very, very big.
Because we wanted to make
a big impact in the region
and on the world.
And second, it was
very important for us
for that to be meaningful.
So should not just
be about money
or bringing
something big, but it
should have a more
social element
of improving the region,
improving the lives of people
as well.
And that's when the
process started.
And along the way,
Magnus can tell us
some of the ideas we looked at.
We looked at many before
we ended up on Careem.
But I'll let Magnus--
MAGNUS OLSSON: So
the code name of this
was actually Project Bamboo.
And I think the idea
was that bamboo--
you put it in the ground,
and then you water it.
For a very long time
you don't see anything,
and then it just goes up.
So we looked at many
different ideas.
And as typical consultants,
we could not really even
have a coffee chat
without slides.
We have these slides--
we still have them--
that have meaningful on one
axis and big on the other axis.
And we had plotted
different things.
Among the shortlist was to
do something in health care.
We felt that health
care was very important.
And the region could need
improvements in that area.
We looked at education.
And we also looked
at a bunch of stuff,
but one favorite was fish farms.
Food is super important.
Rising population, rising middle
class, people need protein.
Fish is one of the best
sources of protein.
And you can put the fish farm
in the middle of the desert.
It doesn't even have to
be close to the ocean.
And you just add some fish,
and you add some water,
and then you get it.
And it's perfect!
And we even have this
sort of the fish version
of peak pricing, which is if
market price for fish is low,
you just keep them
for two days longer.
VRINDA SINGH: Keep them alive.
MAGNUS OLSSON: Exactly.
So we were quite excited
about this for a little while.
And then we realized
that we were
going to smell like fish every
day we came home from work.
So we said maybe not.
And when we first had the
idea of transportation,
it was from our jobs as
consultants traveling around
in the region.
And for the business traveler,
transportation was a pinpoint.
You land in Riyadh, you
land in Kuwait and Qatar,
and you call this one guy
that you have on the phone.
Because everyone has a guy.
And I had Nurr in
Kuwait, Naushad
in Doha, Adeeb in Abu Dhabi.
And you call this guy
and say, hey, I'm here.
Can you come pick me up?
This was how
transportation was working.
And you never showed up on time.
You got lost on the way
to your client meeting.
You had to pay with cash.
You had to haggle on the price.
It was just not great.
So there were people
telling us if you do this,
we might be interested to
be your first customer.
And at first we were
not super excited,
because this did not look
big, and it definitely
did not look meaningful.
So you get a second
chance in life.
You are a survivor
of brain surgery.
And then you're going to go
and do a transportation app.
It did not feel
meaningful at all.
It has gotten more and more
meaningful over the years.
But already from
the beginning, we
realized that there
is an opportunity
here to really improve
the lives of people.
On the one hand,
customers that don't have
an easy way to move
around, particularly
women, but also men.
In the UE, it's easy.
But in countries like Saudi
Arabia, Pakistan, Egypt,
it's more tricky.
And on the other hand, there is
an opportunity to create jobs.
Unemployment is very high.
Youth unemployment
is super high.
And at the same time, we don't
have any public transport
infrastructure in most places.
So this was an opportunity to
actually build public transport
infrastructure, create jobs,
and enable people to go and live
their lives.
So we said, oh, maybe this
is actually quite meaningful,
and it can actually
be quite big.
And then to be sure, we renamed
it Careem, which obviously,
in Arabic means generous,
so that we would always
remember that the core value
was one of doing something
generous for the region.
VRINDA SINGH: And when you
dreamt of making an impact,
did you ever quantify
this is where
we want to be five
years from now,
this is what big looks like?
What was the early
vision for Careem?
Mudassir, you can talk about
how the vision expanded.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: So we have
been positively surprised
on the pace at which
things have moved.
And from the beginning we
said, let's do something big.
So we did the math on how big
this opportunity could be.
So we knew that we were
getting into something big.
But I remember when we did
our first business plan
and presented to investors,
we put a mark for 2017--
this year-- so 2012 to 2017.
We are eight times bigger
than we expected us to be now.
So we really had
no idea this would
happen so quickly and so big.
And over time, we have become
more ambitious as well.
We knew this was
a big opportunity.
But in the first version
of the business plan,
we said, let's focus on the GCC.
So we said GCC, it's
a big enough market.
We are based here.
We can tackle it.
And then we realize
after the first year
that this business can
be a lot more scalable.
So we said, why limit
ourselves to GCC?
People in Egypt, people in
Pakistan, people in Morocco
need the service as well.
And we can create
jobs, and we can
provide mobility to people
in these markets as well.
So we said, let's
expand the scope
to become the
broader Middle East.
Then we said what we're doing
is not just movement of people,
but we can start
moving things as well.
So deliveries and
those kind of things.
So that added another big
opportunity to the mix.
And then lastly we realized
that the cities that we are in,
the Cairos, and the Karachis,
and the Lahores of the world,
there is absolutely no public
transport in these markets.
And we saw ourselves becoming
the transportation system
for the cities.
So then we basically
said, look, our job
is to crowdsource or crowd
fund public transport
infrastructure.
And we will do this
in a way that it
will create a lot of jobs
and income opportunities
for people.
VRINDA SINGH: And is that
on the map right now?
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: It is
on the map at the moment.
So our aspiration is to
basically for the cities
that we are in, become
the most affordable,
the most accessible
transportation option.
So if even someone
is taking a bus,
we need to make sure that we
make that experience better
for that person.
If someone is using
bikes, we want
to be part of that
journey as well.
We really literally
want to build
an efficient and reliable
mobility solution
for people in our cities.
And the opportunity
is, of course, massive.
This is not anything that we
had imagined five years ago.
So every year the opportunity
somehow looks bigger.
We're just waiting to see
what will be next year.
Because every year we think this
is the maximum we can get to.
And then somehow it
becomes even bigger.
VRINDA SINGH: So from
the time that you
got your first
funding, you got valued
as the unique camel
of the Middle East,
and you were valued
at over a billion.
Was there a difference in
reaction by the end of it?
You were like, yeah, of
course, it's going to happen.
How has the emotional
quotient and the relationship
between both of you changed
one success after the other?
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: It all
happens a bit gradually.
So it doesn't happen abruptly.
So you're going through
it one step at a time.
And you're always
very busy as well.
VRINDA SINGH: You both, yes.
Absolutely.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA:
I think you don't
get enough time to celebrate,
enough time to reflect.
So it's been gradual.
We still feel the same
that we did five years ago.
We're not necessarily
worried about the day
to day anymore like we
were until last year.
Now we at least
have the opportunity
and the mental capacity
to think a bit long term.
MAGNUS OLSSON: Two weeks.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: Yeah.
We monitor our growth
at every 15 minutes.
VRINDA SINGH: Yeah,
I've been part of your--
I think reaching 500,000
trips or something.
It was a big thing.
And everyone was awake
at 3:00 in the morning.
So was there any part
in this journey that you
both fundamentally disagreed?
And then how did
you deal with that?
MAGNUS OLSSON: So I was
thinking about this.
I would definitely
have disagreements.
They happen quite
often, actually.
But I think the beautiful thing,
and why I feel so blessed,
and I can speak for
Mudassir as well--
it's fascinating
that while we are
quite different
from our backgrounds
and where we come from,
we have a value system
that is very aligned.
So while we might have opinions
or views or a pet project
that one of us wants to pursue
or a professional vision
this way or that way, on
values we were always aligned.
So what happens is that even if
we have a strong disagreement
on a content topic, I always
value Mudassir's view,
because I know that it
comes from a point of values
and ethics.
So I think we hear
each other out.
Sometimes we have to say,
OK, let's take a break
and sleep on this.
I think sleep on something
is good advice in general.
But there's so much basic trust
and respect for the human being
and for the value set
that disagreements
on content topics, they don't
seem as big or as important.
VRINDA SINGH: And
then when you speak
of values, that's something
that really defines Careem.
And obviously, I
think everyone's
had a chat with
Careem drivers, Careem
captains at some point of time.
And they all say that
you've changed their lives.
And that's like Spider
Man, with great authority
comes great responsibility.
How does that shape
your vision of Careem,
the future of Careem?
How does that play in?
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: I think
it's a good question.
And as we were celebrating
our five years,
the one word that kept coming
back was responsibility.
There are approximately 300,000
captains and their families
dependent on Careem today.
So it's a big burden
on our shoulders.
And we hear this from the
captains from time to time.
So oftentimes when I get in the
car, and they know who I am.
They pray for me and my family
that we are so grateful,
that there are so many
families, my family,
my kids are going to school as
a result of what you have done.
So just as a good
reminder that there's
a big responsibility
towards these people who
literally have built Careem.
Careem would not be
here if they had not
joined and given their
full heart and effort
to make it happen.
And if you were always the
underdog in the region,
and we have been
competing against 10 times
our balance sheet.
And even on the
technology front,
we have been relatively humbled.
And the thing that has
really pulled us through
is the devotion
of these captains.
They have given you, our
customers, a better service
compared to what the same
captains give to competition
because of the bond
and the emotional link
that they have with us.
So we are super, super grateful
for their contributions
and efforts.
And we want to make sure that
we can recognize it and fulfill
that responsibility
towards them.
But we also have
a responsibility
towards the region we feel.
Careem's mission is to build
an awesome organization that
inspires in the region.
So the full mission
is, by the way,
simplifying and
improve the lives
of people and to build an
awesome organization that
inspires.
And given how far we have come--
and it's a bit sad
that we've already
become one of the largest
platforms, internet platforms
in the region.
Because I wish there
were many more.
But it has happened as a result
of the whole ecosystem support
in bringing us this far.
And now we have a
responsibility to the region
and to the ecosystem as well
to give back in some shape.
So for example, I
remember a year ago
when the refugee crisis
was at its peak--
and this is such
a regional topic.
There are more refugees in
this region than any other part
of the world.
We are the largest
contributor of refugees
and the largest
host of refugees.
We actually felt that
this is a local problem
that we need to own up to
and do something about.
So we partnered up
with a refugee agency,
and we launched a car
pack in all of our markets
where people could
take those trips.
And then some part of that
money plus some matching
goes to the refugees.
So we want to make sure that
we use our platform, our reach,
our brand to also tackle some
of the region's biggest issues.
Because this is our region.
We need to improve it.
If you're not going to take
this on, who else will?
So there is a responsibility
towards making the region
better as well.
VRINDA SINGH: And then what
is the future of Careem?
And this is going to
be my last question,
and then we'll open it up.
But we've heard reports of
Careem prototypes coming out,
partnerships with the
idea of you getting
into beyond the Uber
Eats type stuff,
but into more advanced stuff.
So what is the vision of Careem?
Where do you see yourself
five years from now?
And obviously, it's
going to be eight x that.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: So
we are thinking 2030.
That's a magic
number in the region.
MAGNUS OLSSON:
Everyone has a 2030.
VRINDA SINGH: So
there's Expo 2020,
and then there's Careem 2030.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: We have
a 2020 version as well,
but it's a bit more incremental.
So it's not as
crystal clear yet,
because we're still in the
process of drafting it.
But we have a big
opportunity in the region.
And there is a big handicap.
And the opportunity is
one to use the internet
to leapfrog into
a better future.
The internet is one of the best
instruments for leapfrogging.
We have done this with
transportation a little bit
where it's actually more
efficient to transport people
through our type of systems
than with buses and metros.
Mobile phones did that
for text telephony.
E-commerce is doing this for
shopping malls and commerce
infrastructure.
So we believe that
internet can be
a huge savior, can be a huge
instrument of leapfrogging
for the region.
And the region
needs to catch up.
We have 700 million people
that live in the region.
This is 10% of the
world's population.
And we have not built
the infrastructure
that other parts
of the world were
able to build to provide the
quality of life for the people.
So we want to make
sure in some shape
or form that we take full
advantage of the internet
as a leapfrogging mechanism
to leapfrog the region
into a better future.
So that's the opportunity.
Now the bottleneck
is the following.
The region is not one.
It's not the United
States of America.
This region is made up
of 20, 30 countries.
And it's quite
challenging to operate
in the region in a seamless way.
So you guys know this.
To build internet
services like Careem,
you need certain
building blocks.
You need credit cards.
You need payments.
You need last mile delivery.
You need messaging
infrastructure.
You need good maps.
You need all these building
blocks that don't necessarily
exist in our region at the same
level of quality as needed.
So what we had to
do in many cases,
we had to build
this infrastructure.
We built our own places database
on top of Google, of course.
We have integrated with a lot
of operators in the region
to just be able to send a
message to our customers.
We've done payment integrations
with Fawry in Egypt, OneCard
in Saudi, someone
else in Pakistan.
So the building
blocks are missing,
which ends up creating
a lot more work
to build the services.
And with that more work comes
more resource requirements.
You need more engineers, more
product managers, more funding,
but that's not available.
So there's a huge
opportunity to leapfrog.
But the region, the
way it's structured,
the lack of building blocks
and the lack of building blocks
that tie across the region
is hampering the growth.
So we are trying to figure
out what role can we
play in bringing the cost of
launching these services down.
Just like let's say Google
has done it for marketing.
Start-ups can market a lot
more efficiently using Google.
Google Cloud is doing
for infrastructure--
what can we do to enable
more internet commerce
to happen in the region
and over time leapfrog us
into a better future?
VRINDA SINGH: Questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
It's great to hear from
captains that they're
very grateful for the thing
you've enabled for them.
And I don't want to
ruin that in any way.
What I find interesting is that
you say they're very grateful.
In my experience, I see
them with two phones--
Uber and Careem.
So one is, what do you think
is happening with loyalty
indicating the economy?
And what are you trying to do
to get people to use Careem
or captains to use Careem more?
And third, do you care?
Because potentially it doesn't
matter-- as long as you
get enough demand
on your platform,
then the captains
will automatically
steer towards Careem.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: I think
this is a good question.
And I think mostly in Dubai--
Dubai is a demand
constrained market.
There's not a
shortage of supply.
So from a captain's
perspective, it's
a rational choice
to have both devices
so that it can get more work.
So if I wear the
captain's hat, and if I
want what's best
for the captain,
then we should allow them
to have both devices.
Over time, when we
have so much work
that they can't afford not
to have a second device,
we are happy to try
and encourage them
to just have one device.
But for now it is the
reality of the market.
And I've had some captains--
this is actually very beginning
when competition was
coming to market--
this is 2013, and we have been
working with some captains
for some time.
When competition came in, they
invited a lot of our captains.
And they offered them
insane amounts of money
not to work with us.
And many captains of course--
we had built that relationship
with them--
turned them down.
But there were
some captains that
called me personally
and said, look,
I want to let you know
that I really appreciate
working with you and
everything that you've
done for me and my family, but
I need to look out for my family
as well.
And this is a great offer.
So they were
basically grudgingly--
they didn't want to, but there
was so much money at stake.
And these guys have
such low buffers
on the financial freedom
that they have to do it.
And we understand
and respect it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So my question is
about work culture.
So as you've gone through
this phase of crazy growth,
many new offices,
new people, how
do you or how have you made sure
that the core values of Careem
live in each and
every office with each
and every new employee?
MAGNUS OLSSON: It's
a great question.
And it's something that
I think we are struggling
with every single day.
First of all, it's
hard to just capture
the culture in something
that you can easily share.
And then it's hard to spread it.
Maybe a bit of a
history or context.
The first thing we did on the
first day of starting Careem,
which was the first of Ramadan,
Mudassir came to my place
in Abu Dhabi.
The first thing we
did was we sat down,
and we wrote our values.
So that was the
first thing we did.
And then those values
have evolved a little bit
and so has the culture.
But I think at the
core of the culture
are these elements of
essentially three elements.
The first element
is that we really
want to do something
meaningful, and we really
want to be of service.
That is of service to our
customers, to our captains,
to our fellow colleagues.
The second is this sort of
crazy ambitious let's shoot
for the moon type of
notion that if you're
going to do something,
why do it smaller?
And the third one is
the idea of ownership.
We want everyone to
feel like a co-founder.
feel like this is--
Careem is theirs.
You're not an employee.
So we talk about this.
We have our values codified.
And we're going through a
values refresh right now.
Because I think that as
the organization evolves,
we probably need to
polish them a little bit
or adapt them a little bit.
We try to celebrate our values.
We try as much as possible
to talk about our values
and embed them in
how we do things.
I think values needs to become
part of the process as you do--
you want to care for the
captain first and make sure
that someone is raising
that flag every time you
meet to talk about anything.
It gets increasingly harder
with multiple locations.
I think for a relatively
young organization--
we're five years old, and we
are in 13 countries, 80 cities.
We don't have
offices everywhere,
I don't even know
how many offices.
We have a lot of offices.
And making sure that sort of
goes everywhere, it's tricky.
We have-- I think you guys
probably do all the same--
but we have weekly all
hands where we really
try to get everyone
together so that everyone
hears the same story
and the same values.
But yeah, it's a
work in progress.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: This is
one of those things that's
harder than people think it
is, but it's super important.
AUDIENCE: What's your view
on autonomous transport?
And how is that going to affect
your captains in the long term?
What's your story to them?
AUDIENCE: We can't
hear your question.
Sorry.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA:
So the question
was on autonomous transport
and its potential impact
on our captains.
So our view is that other than
some parts of the region--
Dubai and maybe Saudi--
it's going to take a
while for it to happen,
both from the perspective
of labor is relatively cheap
and the cost of the autonomous
will be high at the beginning.
And second, the traffic maybe
is a bit more unpredictable
in some cities.
So the technology will
have to evolve a bit for it
to be functional.
So we have a bit more time,
maybe other than one or two
markets.
And for now, there is
such a huge problem
of youth unemployment
in the region
that we want to
get as many people
behind the wheel making
money as possible so
that we take them away from
other non productive pursuits.
So we are purely focused on
let's create as many jobs
as we can as fast as we can.
And then in parallel,
we have recently
started a social impact
and sustainability
unit which is looking
at how do we make sure
that the families of our
captains and the captains
themselves get the required
education they need so
that over time they
don't just depend
on this as a form of living.
So we have done
some things already,
but some border
initiatives will come out
on the education
front for our captains
and their families
in the near future
so that they're not
dependent on it.
VRINDA SINGH: So talking
about behind the wheel,
does the Saudi women driving,
how does that affect you?
Is that going to affect you?
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA:
This is great news.
We are all very excited.
Despite many people feeling that
we will be negatively impacted,
we just believe that, one,
this is the right thing to do.
And we should just always
be on the right side.
And second, more
practically, this
is just going to create a more
open and more mobile society.
And this will benefit us
tremendously in the long run.
But we have celebrated
that announcement.
MAGNUS OLSSON: We hope that the
first woman driving in Saudi
would be a captain.
VRINDA SINGH: That
would be amazing!
MAGNUS OLSSON: But
the numbers are huge.
There's estimates that about
somewhere between 2 and 1/2
and 3 million women
in Saudi today
would want to be part
of the workforce,
but they are not because
they don't have a way
to get to and from work.
We are trying to
do our bit there,
but this is going
to be a huge step.
VRINDA SINGH: Game changing.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question with respect
to the Emirates here.
Do you have Emirates drivers?
MAGNUS OLSSON: So
in the Emirates,
I would say all our captains
are ex-pat captains.
We have one friend, Emirates
pilot, who drove for a day
to show that this is
actually something great.
But I think, obviously, in
other countries it's different.
But one example that
is quite remarkable
is about a year and
a half ago in Saudi,
all our captains in Saudi, they
were ex-pat captains as well.
And the idea that a
Saudi would be a captain
was almost unthinkable.
And I think it was
unthinkable both
for there was some stigma
around driving as a profession.
And there was also some
cultural considerations
about having a Saudi man in the
same car as a Saudi woman who
was our primary customer.
So that was an almost
unthinkable thought.
And then a few things happened.
We realized that if we
wanted to continue growing,
we needed to get more captains.
And there were a lot of Saudis
that were prime candidates.
Economic times
with low oil prices
also created a need
for a lot of people
to have additional income.
And then our sort of continuing
spreading the message that you
can be your own entrepreneur.
So we finally started
getting a few Saudi captains.
But we saw in the beginning
that it was not really
socially acceptable.
Cancellation rates
was higher when
customers got a Saudi captain.
And so this experiment, we were
like, let's see how this works.
And now a year
and a half later--
I don't know the latest number,
but 95% of our customers-- so
basically all our growth
over the last year and a half
has been Saudi captains.
So witnessing that social
change over a year and a half,
it's just completely remarkable.
So we have to push a
bit on this in the UE.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: And
I think in some markets
we've also seen it's a
relatively conservative part
of the world.
So a lot of men have
never been in such close
proximity with a girl that
was not their mother, wife,
or sister.
So it is creating some
interesting dynamics as well.
They get in the car,
and some of these guys
don't know how to react.
And sometimes, very
non-intentional gestures
can be seen as threatening.
So because of this
social change that
is unraveling, as
a result of it,
we're having to change
the more basic things.
These are the words that
you use to address a female.
This is something
that you cannot do.
And it's only they are
doing this out of malintent.
They don't know.
They've never been in that
position, in that situation.
It's fascinating the
kind of social change
that is happening to society.
MAGNUS OLSSON: And then just
as recently as today, we
have this week the all hands.
And in every all hands we try
to have a captain be part of it,
either in the office
or as some other part.
And today we had two
female captains who
joined us from Tanta in Egypt.
And it was mother and daughter.
And they were both driving for
Careem, using the same car,
doing different shifts.
And they were super excited!
And they spoke to us about how
this is changing perception.
And that it's a great way for
people to enter the workplace.
And because it's
flexible, you can do it
at your own time and
your own boundary.
So it's exciting
what's happening.
AUDIENCE: Were they
driving in Egypt?
MAGNUS OLSSON: Yeah,
in Tanta in Egypt.
VRINDA SINGH: You
had a question?
AUDIENCE: It all looks
to me like smooth sailing
after almost five years,
very rosy and beautiful.
I'd be interested to
hear about the toughest
moments in the past five years.
At what point maybe you
thought about quitting?
Or maybe you don't
have such moments,
but what were the toughest
moments for each of you?
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: I
think the question
is which ones to start with?
MAGNUS OLSSON: Yeah, exactly.
It's never a smooth ride.
There's been many tough moments.
I think the obvious ones are
raising money in the region.
It's not easy.
It's still not easy.
But I think every round of
funding we have raised, A,
it took a very long time.
And we were so out of
money, at the brink
of survival, every single time.
And in the early
days, we could maybe
plug it by putting a little
bit of our savings in there.
But then as you grow bigger,
you don't have enough savings
to plug the hole.
And the feeling
of responsibility
for our colleagues, for our
captains, for our customers,
and realizing that, man,
what's going to happen?
That's been tough, stressful.
But not necessarily
feeling, hey,
we're going to quit doing this.
But that stress has been
intense over the years.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: I
think that's funding.
I had more funding
related stresses as well.
MAGNUS OLSSON: I also think--
if I may continue--
think the first time we
had a fatal accident in one
of our cars.
The first time was
actually a captain who
was not on a ride with Careem.
But he was a Careem captain who
he was doing something else.
But he had an accident, and
unfortunately he passed away.
And then it just gets very real.
We look at all these
growth dashboards--
and we care a lot
for our captains.
We spend a lot of
time with them.
But that was a moment of,
wow, this is really real.
And are we doing everything
we can to keep our customers
and captains safe?
So yeah, that was
a tough moment.
VRINDA SINGH: Any
other questions?
Yes, please?
AUDIENCE: I just want
to know, starting
from UAE, what's
your relationship
with the government, RTA?
Where is it going?
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA:
Overall, our relationship
with most governments
is very healthy.
It doesn't always
start healthy, but I
think after we explain to
them the benefits that we
can bring to the cities
and the countries,
it becomes much better.
But at the very
fundamental level,
as we discussed
a bit earlier, we
are building the
public transport system
in the cities, which in
most cases doesn't exist.
And there's a big need to
build that infrastructure.
And the governments don't
have the physical space
in many cases to build it.
So they recognize the
value that's being added.
And second, unemployment is
a huge issue in most markets.
And when they start
looking at some
of the numbers that
have been done already
or some of the numbers
that can be done,
then they turn around
that perspective.
Now, of course, there are some
vested interest in every city.
In some cities there are larger
vested interest than others.
But for the most part, we're
not disrupting anything.
If you think of it,
we are filling a void
that existed in our markets.
So in most of our markets,
there weren't buses, metros,
or even big taxi systems before
we entered those markets.
So we're really enabling
it for the first time
versus disrupting.
So in the UAE, we have a good
relationship with the RTA.
We were the first ones to
sign up to be regulated.
We've done the same in Saudi.
We're doing the same in
Egypt, Pakistan, Jordan.
So we do recognize
that what we are doing
is important enough that
it needs to be regulated.
And we just want to make sure
that the regulation does not
stifle innovation
and does not stifle
growth of this platform and
the impact that we can make.
AUDIENCE: Have you considered
having a loyalty program?
And if yes, why don't
you yet have it?
MAGNUS OLSSON: Have we
considered a loyalty program?
Yes!
AUDIENCE: Just a
little background,
because I use Careem, like,
three times a day maybe.
And every time I ask
myself why the users
don't have a loyalty program.
MAGNUS OLSSON: I think
it's a great question.
I think it's a matter of
having the resources to make
it happen.
As you guys know, it takes a lot
of great minds to build stuff.
And there's so
many things we need
to build, even in the core.
Like our captain app needs
to get so much better.
Our customer app
needs some polish,
our core sort of
marketplace engine
that does the dispatching.
So it's definitely
something that we
would love to look at and do.
We recognize the value
of loyal customers.
I think this sort of stop
gap that we have been doing,
as you know, is that
we have partnered
with a few other
loyalty programs.
So that you can both
earn points with them,
or if you have points
with someone else,
convert it into Careem,
put it into your wallet
and use Careem.
But yes, it's on the long list.
VRINDA SINGH: Perfect.
One last question?
AUDIENCE: So you
talked about building
an awesome
organization, but you've
had some challenges and
some very public challenges
with certain hires.
What have you learned
from that, and how do you
maintain at the top?
MAGNUS OLSSON: When we
think about building
an awesome organization,
what does that mean?
And I think Mudassir has
this inspirational vision
of building an institution--
an institution that actually
produces world class parts and
services, an institution that
cares for the community, an
institution that will outlast
us and everybody else.
And there's a fourth
dimension of--
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA:
Leadership factory.
MAGNUS OLSSON: Yeah.
An institution is a company
that actually produces leaders.
So people will come
to Careem for a while,
whether they stay for
a year or 10 years,
or they will graduate and go
out and do other amazing stuff.
Like Google.
We look up to Google being
a leadership factory.
Now, how do you
make that happen?
And I think it's all
about the people.
And it's about
making sure that you
have a 100% alignment
on the values of what
you're trying to do.
I think that's the
biggest learning.
And that you have
it particularly
with the leaders that are going
to influence a lot of people,
that you have an alignment
on what's the culture we
are aspiring to create here.
What does that mean?
What does what it not mean?
And there's no rights
and wrongs on culture,
but I think we are starting
to have a pretty strong view
of this is the culture we want.
And it will not
work for everyone.
AUDIENCE: If you think about
creating another business,
which one would it be?
VRINDA SINGH: 2040.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA:
Let me go first.
For me, it would be
a school, education.
It's what the region needs most.
And I think we'd love
to figure out a way
that we can educate more and
more people in the region
to go out and realize
their full potential.
There are a lot of
intrinsic abilities
that are not getting the
right polish and impact.
VRINDA SINGH: Magnus,
are you still thinking?
MAGNUS OLSSON: Yeah.
I think if I knew that I
wanted to do something else,
then I would not be
at Careem anymore.
Because then I would
go pursue that.
Because I am of the
belief that if you
know what your purpose
is, you have to follow it.
You cannot waste your
time doing something else.
So for now, I feel
what we're doing--
and we're just
starting-- but I feel
that using the
platform of Careem
to continue to improve
people's lives.
And transportation
is one where there's
a lot of adjacencies
that we are looking at
and that we'll follow.
So it's still on the path
of online to offline.
We're creating income,
generating opportunities
for people.
That's amazing.
We're not entertaining people.
We're allowing people
to make a living.
And I'm super
excited about that.
VRINDA SINGH: Thank you so much
for taking time out and talking
with us.
[APPLAUSE]
We have a small
something for you.
MAGNUS OLSSON:
Thank you so much.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
SPEAKER: I was really hoping
that they were giving us
the next business ideas.
[LAUGHTER]
MAGNUS OLSSON:
And I think also--
I know Neil was
traveling, I think,
from the very early days.
We have had a lot of support
from you guys as well.
There were early days
when we might have used--
this should probably
be off record--
where we might have had
some slightly hacked version
of some API key.
And we always got the
support to make sure
that we could be up and
running and continue to run.
Even when we had to call
in the middle of the night
to wake up people
and get support.
So I think we've got
a lot of support.
And we're very
grateful for that.
MUDASSIR SHEIKHA: And
inspiration as well.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
MAGNUS OLSSON: Thank you.
VRINDA SINGH: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]